-Now, Ice,
you're a man of many talents.
You're an accomplished
actor, producer,
musician --
Grammy-winning musician.
You're also --
You're also known for not being
afraid to speak your mind
and for your no-holds-barred
commentary on Twitter.
So I thought we could go through
some of your tweets
and you could tell us
a little more
about your thoughts behind them.
Is that okay?
Is that okay by you?
-This should be good.
-All right. Good.
Let's start with this one.
This says...
"I remember when I said I had
breakfast at IHOP or Denny's.
MFs lost it.
Like there's some Gucci egg
somewhere I should be eating.
LOL. SMH."
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, yeah.
I mean, I eat at normal spots.
I mean, breakfast is breakfast.
An egg is an egg.
You know, like, where are you
supposed to eat breakfast?
At Tiffany's or something?
Like, people bug out.
If I say I go to Taco Bell,
they're like,
"You eat at Taco Bell?"
I'm like, "I don't have, like,
a Mexican chef fly in
to make me tacos.
This is how we eat tacos."
-Yeah. It tastes delicious.
Yeah, exactly.
"Bonus ice cold fact: you can't
change some of your friends
so you're gonna have to change
some of your friends."
[ Laughter ]
That one had me thinking
a little bit.
-I mean, some of your friends
won't grow up.
Some of your friends
are still on that BS.
You know what I'm saying?
-Oh, I see.
-You gotta say, "You know,
I got to let you go, man."
-Oh, so you can't change
some of your friends
so you're gonna have to "change"
some of your friends.
Wow! Wow! I love it.
That's a Gucci egg.
-There you go. Exactly.
-[ Laughs ] I like this one.
You said, "Don't worry about
what people think about you.
Because they probably
don't think about you
that much anyway."
[ Applause ]
-That's true.
-Yeah.
-I mean, even when people
are gossiping,
they'll pick somebody out
and they might talk about them
for five minutes,
but after they finish with that,
they go back to their life.
-Yeah.
-So they don't really have a lot
of time to think about you.
So don't worry about it.
It's not something
they do often.
And if someone's
doing you constantly,
then they have a problem,
not you.
-This is what I'm ta--
This is why I follow you.
This is what I'm talking about.
Let's do a couple more here.
"Whenever someone tries
to diss me by saying I'm old,
I'm like, 'That's a fact.
Where's the insult?'"
[ Laughter ]
-You know what I'm saying?
Aren't we all trying to get old?
I mean, what's the --
what's the alternative?
-Yeah.
-You know?
So I'm happy every day I live.
I've just turned 63.
You know, I'm still thin in the
waist, handsome in the face.
You know what I'm saying?
-That's what
I'm talking about, bud.
-That's what I'm talking about.
-Last one here says,
"Twitter is like a friend
I talk to sometimes...
that has a million heads.
LOL."
That's the truth.
-Yeah.
If you do like I do, I'm on --
My Twitter name is
FINALLEVEL.com.
And I talk to my fans.
I use Twitter sometimes
to get answers,
and I get feedback from them,
so I can put a question out
and I'll get a thousand answers.
First thing, you got to get
all the dummies
off of your Twitter feed
so that you can have a real line
of, you know, information
moving back and forth.
But, you know, I got --
I get rid of them real quick.
I've got a hair-trigger
block button. You know?
And, also, I like using mute.
If you're new to Twitter,
use mute,
because then the person
doesn't know they blocked,
and then they just yell
into the abyss.
They yell into
the void of Twitter
thinking you're
still hearing them.
-Ice-T. I love you, man.
Best to the family.
Come back whenever
you want to, pal.
Congrats on everything, man.
I'm happy for you.
Ice-T, everybody.